buenas noches compatriotas
[Música]
recibo con la más profunda humildad
esta decisión sagrada del pueblo
costarricense
para mí este no es un momento para
festejar
este resultado para mí no es una medalla
ni un trofeo
sino una enorme responsabilidad
colmada del resto de dificultades que
todos nosotros vamos a solucionar en
primer lugar le doy gracias infinitas a
medios y alas a todas las mujeres y
hombres costarricenses
así como a mi familia por haber acudido
a una jornada democrática que nos
enorgullece y que nos hace brillar ante
el mundo somos de las mejores
democracias del mundo
envío
[Música]
envió mi reconocimiento a don josé maría
figueres olsen y a todas las personas
que votaron por él
lo felicito
al día y le pido le ruego humildemente a
don josé maría y a su partido que
trabajemos juntos para hacer posible lo
que don jose maria
[Aplausos]
para hacer posible y lo digo se lo ruego
humildemente
trabajemos juntos para hacer
posible lo que el mismo don jose maría
llamó el milagro costarricense costa
rica lo mejor está por venir
[Aplausos]
entiendo el mandato que he recibido hoy
como una obligación para ejercer mi
liderazgo como honradez con eficiencia
transparencia y austeridad
pero también con solidaridad hacia las
personas más vulnerables de nuestra
patria
asumo el sagrado compromiso de hacer un
gobierno
democrático de diálogo respetuoso de la
constitución de la ley y de los valores
costarricenses
[Aplausos]
una vez más compatriotas
los costarricenses hemos cumplido con
creces y ejemplaridad su tarea
ahora nos toca a los que hemos sido
electos cumplir con la nuestra no se
vale fallar la costa rica no se vale
fallarle a costa rica
[Aplausos]
discutamos lo que haya que discutir no
hay problema
discutámoslo y busquemos y encontremos
soluciones de maneras conjuntas
costarricenses eso sí con la
colaboración de todos sin que nadie
saque el hombro costa rica nos necesita
a todos ya todas unidos de la mano si
superamos nuestras diferencias con el
propósito de que costa rica triunfe el
país estará a salvo porque tendremos más
y mejores trabajos
así como mejores servicios públicos la
educación para nuestros hijos que
añoramos la salud que necesitamos y la
seguridad que merece nuestra patria
modernizaremos juntos costarricenses el
estado y generaremos juntos también las
urgentes
oportunidades para todos los que quieran
trabajar
agricultores e industriales en nuestras
mujeres jóvenes emprendedores servidores
públicos
una ciudadanía valiente no tengan duda
una ciudadanía valiente nos da mandará
justamente cada minuto lo mejor de
nosotros yo les he prometido mi mayor
esfuerzo mi sudor y mi lágrimas por
cumplir este compromiso con la patria y
espero de todos ustedes lo mismo porque
es nuestra patria
esta misma noche
guardemos las banderas partidarias
que fácilmente nos pueden dividir y nos
confrontan esta misma noche les pido
humildemente
que nos unamos todos
el azul blanco y rojo de nuestro
5 no partió
de la bandera tricolor que nos
enorgullece
azul blanco y rojo
esa es la única bandera que tiene que
ondear
esta noche en costa rica
apartemos las mezquindades y vanidades
esta misma noche
empezaremos juntos a servir a nuestra
patria
empecemos ya
[Música]
[Aplausos]